all right welcome back everyone to my
round four recap from the Qatar
Masters this one was uh super super
interesting uh there's a fun story tied
with this game which I will get into but
coming in to this round I was paired
against melic ilas from Morocco I
believe he's one of the top players from
Morocco maybe ranked number two in the
country uh he's definitely represented
their Olympia team before for cuz I
found his games from the Olympiad as I
Was preparing for him and coming into
this game I was mainly expecting Pawn E4
which is what he played and we ended up
going into a sicilian and I decided to
play E6 on move two I'm capable of
playing a few different moves um on on
move two uh Knight C6 and D6 also
included but I went for E6 partly
because he played the same opening in a
previous round against nihal sain and
against sain he played G3 after thinking
for maybe like seven or eight minutes so
I figured that I'd repeat the opening
and maybe he wouldn't be super well
prepared but boy was I wrong because he
he came prepared with some very deep
preparation uh starting with
C3 and this is a beginning of
kind of the story of of the opening in
this game because not only was he deeply
prepared but so was I and what ended up
unfolding was we went
into an opening that is super super like
new and trendy that has recently been
played in some very notable games uh and
I'll go forward the next few moves just
to show so after C3 I play D5 he plays
E5 I play D4 and if you follow the top
level chess scene at all especially if
you've been watching the US
championships you may know that the one
and only Hans Neeman recently defeated
LaVon aronian in this exact opening uh
Hans was playing white Hans played D3
and so did my opponent now I had seen
the Hans against ronian game but I also
seen a game that was played yesterday
between Anish giri and aditia matal in
this exact
tournament and this morning before I
played this game I saw an interview I
don't know if it was on CHP India or the
official Qatar Masters YouTube channel
but Anish was talking about his
experience in yesterday's game about how
his opponent was like super super well
prepared hair like blitzed out the first
15 moves of the opening and um out of
curiosity this morning I I saw their
game and I thought it looked interesting
and then I I realized that maybe there's
a possibility my opponent could like use
this weapon that Anish played and that
Hans played recently against me and um
yeah this move D3 at least between Anish
and Hans and I think uh also recently at
the
world junior Championship this was
played pretty sure Hans referenced this
in his interview I was playing in Mexico
the world juniors and next to me there's
a game like Yan subel against rudic
marcan and I saw that um this idea was
played and I was so impressed by the
idea so this morning I I made an effort
to look at the the game
between uh Anish and aditia and I
managed to remember
the the next like 10 to 15 moves of the
game and we basically just repeated
their exact same opening after Knight C6
G3 Knight E7 Bishop
G2 both me and my opponent were
following the game uh from yesterday and
I was very fortunate to have reviewed
this uh this morning after Knight B5
Queen V8 it gets a little a little bit
messy because after white takes on D4 I
don't take back right away because the
Knight defends D4 but first I play A6
Knight A3 and then I take and then after
Knight C4 there's this move Bishop to B4
check um now I didn't really have to
think much about these moves I was
taking a little bit of time to make sure
I was remembering things correctly uh
but the point here is after Bishop D2 I
take on D2 and we should note that the
queen and both Knights are tied down to
defending the E5 Pawn I have three
attackers there's three Defenders so if
white doesn't want to lose a pawn the
only move is King takes D2 and that's
what my opponent played and this is
still the same position as anish's game
from yesterday and in this position
Anish made the reference to this inhuman
move uh I thought there's no way black
finds these moves particularly Bishop D7
is very hard and then in the end Rook to
A7 is absolutely impossible to make
which is Rook A7 and this is a move that
is very difficult to understand and I'll
admit that during the
game I didn't really understand this
move immediately but I knew it was a top
stockfish move like I knew that um any
other move is uh some Advantage for
white and Rook A7 maintains some sort of
equality but I want to make it clear I
did not have any devices on me
um I I played the the inhuman stockfish
move because I looked at this position
this morning it was by some miracle such
such a ridiculous miracle that that I
don't even remember why I checked it
that uh I I saw the game from yesterday
and it happened in my game as well and
once I played Rook A7 my opponent I
think took his first think of the game
uh at least extended think before
playing H4
uh now unfortunately I actually just
forgot what happened in the niche game
uh in this moment I couldn't remember if
an nishe played H4 or something else um
I did just check and he actually played
A4 and the game took a slightly
different route after B5 and then take
and then take and then check and then
here and then there are some eventual
Queen a8s but um yeah after
H4 I was basically on my own and I was
trying to remember the brief analysis I
did this morning um but I I didn't
really analyze super in depth because I
was not expecting this position to occur
in my game but it did and now I had to
figure out what to do um B5 definitely
crossed my mind here but I wasn't sure
about lines with Knight D6 and maybe
some eventual H5 so I played what I
thought was the safest move is H5 uh
preventing white from getting this Pawn
thrust in and kicking my knight and from
here my opponent played Rook to C1 which
I was pretty sure was not played early
on in anisha's game so I I was very
certain that we were in completely fresh
territory and then this is a brand new
position and now I had to figure out
what exactly to do and I knew some ideas
in the position like obviously B5 is an
idea uh the reason I why I didn't play
B5 was I was scared of Knight D6 King E7
and then Knight takes F7 I'm pretty sure
this is like quite strong for white
because if I take there's Knight G5 and
White's winning back the Knight on C6
given that it's attacked twice by the
rook and Bishop so rather than going for
B5 I played the move Pawn to F6 which I
think is very thematic for this position
simply targeting the pawn E5 trying to
get rid of it so uh White doesn't have a
a space advantage in the center and also
to try and um ensure that white can't
make use of this Knight D6 move because
if white plays Knight D6 King E7 uh this
structure is actually very delicate and
yeah once the pawn goes away the Knight
will probably have to go away as well so
after I played F6 my opponent played A4
and he took a very long think to play
this move like over a half hour he he
spent before playing A4 and once we got
to this position I pretty quickly played
the move Pawn
B5 and even though we were in fresh
territory I I was pretty confident with
this move cuz I did remember that aditia
played this in a similar position
against Anish yesterday and it makes
sense now to kick the Knight and there's
not the same tactics with exploiting my
knight on C6 so from here uh my opponent
plays Knight D6
I play King E7 so both our Kings have
Bond clouded uh no castling for either
of us this game and here my opponent
surprised me big time um I'm not sure
what I was expecting but um definitely
not the move that my opponent played he
took the pawn on
F6 basically saying oh no my knight and
yeah I was not anticipating this at all
and then I had to try and figure out
what is his idea can I just take a free
Knight on D6 and I spent a long time
trying to calculate this position and
eventually I concluded that this is
probably a little bit too dangerous for
black cuz white has this move Queen E4
and even though I'm temporarily up a
piece my knight is attacked and white
just has a lot of counterplay and I
don't really have time to take back the
pawn because Queen takes G6 and it's my
who's looking a lot more exposed than
White's King on D2 so after some
deliberation I decided to not take the
Knight but rather take back the pawn on
F6 leaving the Knight on D6 and then my
opponent uh doesn't move his Knight on
D6 he rather counterattacks with Pawn
takes
B5 and here I have another uh decision
to make do I take the pawn do I take the
Knight with my queen with my king and I
figured that if I take the pawn on
B5 I'm allowing Knight F5 check and
white is winning a pawn here my E6 Pawn
is pinned after King F7 he can take and
I wasn't sure if I have much
compensation for being down a pawn in
this position so instead of taking on
B5 I decided to take the Knight on D6
with my king now I should explain I
didn't take with the queen
because I wanted my queen to be on the B
file and we're going to see that after
King takes D6 Pawn takes on C6 I can
throw in the in between move Queen takes
B2 and basically when I took on D6 with
the king I had calculated a very deep
line which basically goes King E1 I
would take on E2 he would take back I
would take on C6 and and I thought the
critical line here is Rook takes C6
which ends up getting uh two minor
pieces for The Rook for white so Knight
and Bishop for rook and pawn I was
calculating even deeper here I was
thinking I would play Rook to
B8 and if he plays Knight F4 I was going
to play maybe some check King F3
E5 uh keep in mind this calculation was
all from when I played King takes G6 so
so uh basically my conclusion was that
black has more winning chances here even
though it's still double-edged um The
Pawn on the a file is just super super
dangerous it's a pass Pawn supported by
the rook and it's very easy for White's
Knight to get sidelined like if he takes
on uh H5 maybe something like King E6
and then yeah my Pawn can run very
quickly and White's pieces are looking a
little bit ridiculous on the King side
so we did not go into any of that let's
go back several moves I really thought
we were going to enter this um this end
game but rather than moving his King in
this position he surprised me
again by sacrificing his Rook on A1 and
yeah when he played Rook C2 I I was very
surprised because I thought that okay I
just take the Rook I'm up material he
does take on D7 but um yeah from here I
thought it should be like simple to
consolidate but then the more I thought
the more I realized that it's not so
easy because white has a lot of
resources especially with my king on D6
and yeah White's piece getting ready to
swarm uh there's ideas of Knight D4 and
Rook C6 and queen E6 so I had to be
super super careful here and the move I
started with was Queen A5 check forcing
the king back to D1
and then I take on D7 with the rook and
when I played this move I was beginning
to feel very comfortable and I thought
like I'm in very good shape to just
consolidate be up material and hopefully
go on to win and the lines I was
calculating uh for one if Queen to E4 I
was going to play Queen F5 just
defending a lot of things on the king
side and then this check doesn't lead to
anything meanwhile Queen takes D4 I just
play King E7 and then D3 would hang so I
was feeling good if uh if Queen E4 is
played I was also feeling good if Knight
takes D4 was played I thought is a
tricky option because I can't really win
the Knight without running into trouble
with Rook C6 and queen E6 but uh if
Knight takes D4 I was going to play
Knight E5 and I'm pretty sure this is
also quite good for black cuz I cover C6
I'm ready to play King E7 and get some
some initiative on the defile on top of
that I'm now threatening Queen A1 to win
the Knight so I thought that the the two
like obvious candidate moves for white
are just better for me but my opponent
played a big surprise in this position
and it was a common theme in this game
that I was overlooking my opponent's
opportunities to sacrifice and in this
position I guess for the second time in
the game my opponent sacrificed The Rook
Rook C6 was played and when this came on
the board just felt like a cold shower I
was vaguely aware of this move but I
like dismissed it pretty early just
thinking I can take and then survive the
checks but once I started calculating I
realized that my king doesn't have a
great place to hide um I had to take on
C6 he took on D4 now note here that I'm
in huge time pressure uh falling almost
below a minute and this is double check
so my King has to move I can't take the
Knight I can't block the check and there
are only a few legal moves for the king
and there's just so many lines where
black gets forked like if I play King C5
I get forked if I play uh
King D6 I was calculating but then Queen
takes E6 and then yeah this did not look
good at all so I ended up playing King
to
C7 uh but the issue here is Queen
C2 and these squares are off limits
these looked like the safest squares but
both moves get forked with Knight C6 so
I had to play King to D6 I want to just
note that um yeah I I played the move
King C7 with two seconds left on my
clock so I was like barely holding on
and once we got to this position I
thought that I'm just losing because
after Queen C6 King E7 Queen takes E6 it
seems like my whole position is
crumbling and I can't play King
d8 because again I get forked so I had
to play King f8 uh this was all kind of
just process of elimination for me I'm
just playing the moves that don't get
forked I wanted to make sure I'm holding
on to my Queen uh but I did have to
abandon my Rook my opponent took the
rook and once we got to this position I
really didn't know what to make of it
but I knew that white is threatening
mate in two with Knight E6 and queen G7
checkmates so I played the only move
which um attempts to get counterplay is
Queen A1 and once we got to this
position I started to calculate and I
realized that white doesn't have a great
way to escape my checks and what ended
up happening is after King D2 Queen B2
King D1 Queen B1 I force the situation
where once his King moves up either to
D2 or E2 I'm ready to sacrifice my queen
uh so he played King E2 and I was just
so relieved to have my next move Queen
takes D3 oh no my queen uh maybe I'll
I'll make um a mer discount code use
coupon code Qatar to save save on merch
shop. rosen.com but uh yeah I played
Queen D3 and the point of this move is
if he takes it then I'm winning because
I have the fork I win back the queen and
this should be a winning end game for
black uh so I was very relieved but
unfortunately I'm not winning in this
position at least I don't think I'm
winning because after King E1 white is
still threatening 96 check and I'm still
uh relatively low on time still kind of
living on increment and what ended up
happening from here is I give a check I
give another check and I saw nothing
better than to repeat the position and
the game ended in threefold ended
peacefully in a
draw I'm not sure if I had a chance to
play for a win in the final position but
I don't think I did I'm pretty sure it
was a draw I I hope I didn't miss any
opportunities in end here but I'm super
curious to check this game with the
engine uh I really held off like it was
a long shuttle ride back to my hotel but
uh the whole ride I I avoided checking
with the engine so let me uh switch to
the other chapter here and we can see
the graph wow so I was never actually
winning I was better at some
point let's get to the critical
moments so yeah the the first 15 moves
at least for me was all opening
preparation big thanks to Anish giri and
aditia matal and Hans Neiman for um for
making this line popular enough for me
to review it this morning but uh yeah
after
H4 wow H5 was just a blunder I thought I
was still following like thematic ideas
but what am I supposed to do so H4 was
maybe a bit
inaccurate I'm just supposed to Castle
here
H5 H5 B5 only
move
wow yeah it's the type of thing like if
I had more time to prepare like if I had
maybe a a few more days or a few more
months to prepare I would build out my
repertoire deeply enough to uh have this
in my files but yeah I don't think I was
going to find that over the board so H5
was a mistake I am worse here F6 was
also a bad
move cuz white can just take
it yeah if takes I was going to take
back I was cting King E1 during the game
but apparently Knight B6 is very
strong wow so I could have just been
much much worse
so unfortunate that my opponent
didn't um didn't punish me didn't play
the the stockfish moves and going
forward from here White's still for
Choice wow so Queen E4 that's such a
hard move to find like the missed
opportunities so far are like hard to
find engine moves so can't play my
opponent for missing that after B take
C6 this is now equal I take on
B2 Rook C2 is a mistake yeah I figured
in the game white should play King E1
and real quick let me just check this
line yeah this is a very deep line I
thought black is for choice in the end
though my opponent told me after the
game he didn't go for this cuz uh yeah
the pawn looks so so
strong so okay Rook C2 black is for
choice but yeah you have to take the
engine evaluation with a grain of salt
cuz it's so tricky to play especially in
time
pressure after Queen A5 I did not play
this accurately so white is winning here
Rook C6 best
move so what did white
miss queen
C2 this is all winning for
White Queen oh Queen takes F6
first
and what was I going to play Rook F oh
Rook F7 just gets mated though because
here in yeah it's Force
mates I would have had to play King
E8 wow so white could have gone into
this line where black is up two
exchanges what is this two Rooks for two
minor pieces and and a pawn but the king
is so
exposed and apparently there's some
forcing variation here
oh look at this Rook E7 Queen takes E7
oh no White's Queen but then the fork
and yeah White's completely
winning so when my opponent took the
Rook that allowed me to escape with the
draw and we see uh we see the same
tactical theme yeah oh no my queen wow
what a game so I was never actually
winning I was only like slightly for
choice
I guess I'm very thankful to have
survived especially towards the end
there man what a crazy crazy
game um yeah again uh big thanks to Hans
nean Anish giri Adit matal
for um for probably being the reasons
why this game took
place uh do I clickbait the thumbnail
just just thank you Hans
nean if he didn't play his game against
leavon aronian I don't think Anish would
have played it yesterday and then I
would not have been aware of this line
to play it today so it's just kind of a
a trickle down effect but that's how we
learn openings by following uh the games
of top
players so anyway um hope you guys
enjoyed this recap this is a fun one uh
probably my craziest game so far of the
tournament uh do stay tuned for more
chess stay stay tuned on Twitch Jonathan
trance is doing coverage every day
twitch.tv/ Rosen and also stay tuned for
more Recaps tomorrow is round 5 I'm
currently 1 and a half out of four but
having a lot of fun so far so do stay
tuned and I'll see you guys soon